Y'all seen, uh, Episode 1 of Season 5, of course, yes?
I'm a man that loves a bromance
I've made a few movies where dudes
Are in love with each other and stuff
So naturally, naturally the Sciles relationship
Is very close to my heart
Um
That being said, as you recall the end of the episode
It's not just those two but everybody going into the library
Writing their initials on the shelf with the yearbooks
And stuff, which right away appealed to me on the
Sentimentality level of like "Aw I'm 45 I think I remember
Going to High School" and stuff like that
But I loved it, it's a beautiful scene, like there we are
At the Beacon Hill High School and watching all the
friends together and that's great
And then they took it one level up
and that's what this show always does and does
so exceptionally well, and why I will tune in and
watch the show and why y'all are here today to see
the people behind it
They gave us something even better, all of a sudden,
We see Scott take out the marker, and he writes
Allison's initials
And, I started bawling as I was watching this scene
I start crying, now I was watching on my laptop and my wife is sitting over at her desk
She's watching a totally different program
She sees me crying and she's like "What's the matter?!"
And I was like "He just wrote Allison's initials
And my wife looked at me like "I can't believe I sleep with you."
Um
But, ladies and gentleman there's a reason we're gathering here today
Man. I , like you , LOVE Teen Wolf. Put it together for Teen Wolf!
We're going to be lucky enough to sit here today and talk to the people behind it
The people that make it happen man
I'm gonna bring them out and give it up for each one as they come out
As if they're , you know, Jesus coming into nazareth or something like that
Without this guy, Ladies and Gentleman, you got no show
Man, he created it, he runs it, he's the man
Give it up for Jeff Davis!
Ah, you know its a boy's world in Teen Wolf, not so much its girl's as well man
There's lots of ladies on this show, ladies who kick ass
Here's one of them, man. Give it up for Shelley Hennig!
Uh, I have watched this kid become such a great actor over the last five seasons
I stole him and I put him into a movie called "Yoga Hosers," man
He is the Teen Wolf, give it up for Tyler Posey!
Jeff: You didn't break anything this time, did you?
Jeff: No broken toe?
Tyler: No broken toes this time!
Tyler: I don't think so
Tyler: May have broke my butt though
Uh, I don't know how you follow an entrance like that
But, there's one guy that's going to be able to do it, man.
He's half of Sciles
Give it up for Dylan O'Brien!
Dylan: Hi!
I'm happy to say, uh, this next person's actually been in my house
Man, she's really cool. Man, give it up for Holland Roden.
Holland: Hi guys!
Almost there, two more people
Man, welcome to the stage, Ladies and Gentleman
The only berry that matters, Dylan Sprayberry!
And last but not least, the man with the ailliterate of name which fits right here at Comic Con
Give it up for Cody Christian!
Okay, we're going to get into it
I'm going to do a few minutes of questions with these guys
Your questions matter far more. So, we'll do a few and then we're going to turn it right over to you guys
But I want to start with that scene I was talking about, Jeff.
I loved it, I was-
Dylan: Wait, I want to inturrupt!
I got a present for you
Yeah?
We have got banned together as a casting crew and gotten you you're own Beacon Hills Lacrosse
The love goes both ways here between this
listen you have
no
idea what this means to me
man, I'm gonna' wear this when I sleep
with that wife of mine *laughter* um okay so
i just talked about before we get out of here the opening
of the season that,
that moment in the library as
a writer i was jealous cus' I was like that
had to come nobody could just create that
He had to take it from his real life
Is that a tradition that you stole from your own life, or what?
Jeff: Uh, no actually. We made it up in the writers room
We have a few good ideas sometimes and uh,
*laughs*
Jeff: Uh, it was actually.. it was inspired by
Uh, the actress who played Allison Argent
Crystal Reed
And it was a way for us-*stops for applause*
It was a way for us to pay tribute to, uh um, one of the actors who had been on the show
I mean in TV these days, uh, the dead pile up. There's so many shows
My favourite show on TV right now, Game of Thrones, where everybody dies
So it's nice to be able to pay tribute to a great actor and a character that I created a long time ago
It feels like now. And, um, to be able to say
Uh, I miss her.
How many - this is season five? Did you ever think you'd be doing five seasons?
We're getting into 5B now and it's 70 episodes.
I gotta say, back in Atlanta, when we were shooting that pilot,
Tyler, did you ever think we would get to 70 episodes?
Oh my God, I don't know, man, 70?
I just, I knew the show was great, I just never had any expectations for anything, but I want it to go forever.
Do you wanna do a few more?
Yes, I would love to.
I think MTV does too, 'cause they just ordered a sixth season. *applause*
More Teen Wolf everybody!
You're coming back too, Dylan.
What?
Hell yea!
Um, that's fantastic. So when are you guys - when did they tell you that sorta thing?
Um, they tell you usually right before this sorta thing.
And I called my lawyer, and I'm like, "Did they give me all the money I wanted?"
And they're like, "No", and I say, "Fine, let's do it anyway."
you, uh we were talking once uh, about like uh the show is very highly rated on MTV but it also has this ghost audience that just finds it illegally online or something
Yes, you all- THAT LADY RIGHT THERE!        you all steal the show. Just raise your hand.
Where are you? There they are. YOU! OUT! Kick them out
Is that Natalie and Karen over there?
They steal the show